today on the matt walsh show president
biden had a town hall event yesterday
and mostly he babbled incoherently as he
tends to do but the coherent parts were
the most disturbing among other things
he called for kids
under the age of 12 to wear masks we'll
talk about why pushing masks on kids
especially at this point
is irrational anti-science and i would
also say abusive
also our five headlines including a new
poll which shows that race relations
are at their lowest point in decades i
wonder who we can blame for that
and jk rowling continues to stand firm
in the face of insane hatred from trans
activists
and also in our daily cancellation i
will address the very intense
very intense backlash from my review of
a bts song will be posted to my youtube
channel this weekend
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show
one of the sad facts among many about
being an adult in this world
is that you have to pay money for
everything all the time
this is one of the most shocking things
to realize as an adult is that wow
everything costs money but there's so
many things you have to pay for monthly
insurance should be the least of your
words you don't need to add that onto
the pile and that's what policy genius
can do for you they can make it
easy to compare home and insurance and
auto insurance in one place they make it
very easy and very cheap
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price
they've saved customers an average of
1200 per year over
what they were paying for home and auto
insurance in the past their team will
handle the paperwork for you
um and set up everything for you all you
got to do is just head to
policygenius.com answer a few questions
about yourself and your property
then policy genius takes it from there
they make it to make it idiot proof
and they make it very affordable for you
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
and find your lowest quotes if you want
to take advantage of this then go to
policygenius.com to get started right
now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
so president biden a town hall event
last night hosted by cnn moderated by
political activist don lemon
anyone deranged enough to sit and watch
the whole thing while it was live may
have noticed that the camera only ever
showed
the front couple of rows in the
auditorium that's because every row but
the few up front
were empty it continues to be you can
see the picture there continues to be
apparent
that the decaying old man waddling
around and speaking in semi-coherent
half sentences
doesn't inspire a lot of enthusiasm what
a shock
now that characterization may have been
a little unfair i have to admit
i shouldn't say that he's semi-coherent
that probably gives him too much credit
here he is answering a question about
when
children under 12 will be able to get
vaccinated and i only know the question
he was trying to answer because it's
written on the screen otherwise i'd be
at a loss
listen it's like the other question is
illogical
and i've heard you speak about it
because you always i'm not being
solicitous but you
you're always straight up about what
you're doing and the question is whether
or not
we should be in a position where you uh
um
are why can't the the
the experts say we know
that this virus is in fact
uh is it it's going to be uh or assuming
we
we know why all the drugs approved are
not temporarily approved but permanently
approved
that's underway too i expect that to
occur quickly well that means you mean
for the fda for the fda yeah
so the federal drug administration
yes a presidential quote that will go
down in history
alongside the only thing we have to fear
is fear itself and i don't know
roosevelt's man and the man in the arena
speech
will also be this quoting what you just
heard there i've heard you speak about
because you always i'm not being
solicitous but you you're always
straight up
about what you're doing and the question
is whether or not we should be in a
position where
you are why can't and the experts say we
know this virus is in fact is
is going to be excuse me we all know the
drugs approved are not temporarily
approved but permanently approved
joe biden 2021 but other times of course
the sentences coming out of his mouth
were more or less intelligible
while the overall point or message made
no sense at all such was the case with
his
answer on uh the question of inflation
you seem pretty confident that that
inflation is temporary but if you're
pumping
all of this money into the economy
couldn't that add to no look here's the
deal moody's today when a wall street
firm not some liberal think tank
said if we pass the other two things i'm
trying to get done
we will in fact reduce inflation
reduce inflation reduce inflation
because we're going to be providing good
opportunities and jobs for people
who in fact are going to be reinvesting
that money back in all the things we're
talking about
okay so by spending trillions of dollars
we will reduce inflation
or excuse me we will not just reduce
inflation but reduce inflation reduce
inflation reduce inflation
maybe inflation is like a witch's curse
and all you have to do is say the
magical incantation three times
and it'll go away magical limitations
after all
have just as much of a chance of
reducing inflation
as a multi-trillion dollar spending bill
does
now it's fun to laugh at the nonsense
but as always the biden
or any other democrat they're the most
terrifying when they are the most
coherent
and i mean coherent in a relative sense
of course the point is that biden
will disturb you the most when you're
able to actually understand what he's
trying to say
and i'd say that was certainly the case
with his answer on
gun violence actually crime is down
gun violence and murder rates are up
guns
i'm the only guy that ever got past
legislation
when i was a senator to make sure we
eliminated assault weapons
the idea you need a weapon that can
have the ability to fire twenty thirty
forty fifty
a hundred and twenty shots from that
weapon whether it's uh
whether it's a nine millimeter pistol
or whether it's a rifle is ridiculous
i'm continuing to push to eliminate the
sale of those things
now uh first of all saying that murder
is up but crime is down is like the
doctor coming in and telling you good
news
your cholesterol levels are good uh bad
news you have ebola
it's not really anything to take solace
in or be proud of if criminals are
committing fewer non-violent crimes
because they're too big they're too busy
murdering people also
it's hard to say that crime generally is
down when places like california
have simply stopped counting crime as
crime
just yesterday there was another video
of two people this time out of tj maxx
in los angeles
strolling casually out of the store with
an arm full of merchandise
that they didn't pay for and they know
the crime
won't be prosecuted won't be counted
this is especially egregious by the way
t.j mass
max where you can get i mean
the guy walking out he's got like 15
pairs of jeans
you could buy those 15 pairs of jeans at
t.j.maxx max
for maybe 15 total but why pay for it
if you have no ethical if you have no no
no moral sense whatsoever
uh you don't care about anything like
that you don't care about being honest
and moral means nothing to you
you're annihilus you're empty inside
go ahead and take it
but on the official record books
there were no crimes committed yesterday
at that tj maxx
in los angeles and that's what biden
means when he says crime is down
the crime that we are counting is down
but i'm burying the lead myself here
because the bigger issue is that joe
biden just came out and said
that he wants to eliminate the sale of
handguns not big scary assault weapons
whatever those
are exactly but handguns he says you
don't need guns that fire
20 or 30 shots well that takes
lots of different kinds of guns off the
table
one wonders how many rounds biden thinks
our guns
should have maybe he thinks we should
all be carrying six shooters like the
old west back in biden's youth
either way it's not conspiracy to say
that biden is coming for our guns
he said it himself and he's doing it in
the name of stopping a gun violence
surge
that has been driven almost exclusively
by criminals who are using guns
that they don't legally own in the first
place the thug on the street corner
shooting someone over drugs or money and
that's what almost all of this is
is already breaking 20 different laws
biden hopes that by adding a 21st law
for him to break
that'll solve the problem perhaps the
criminal will say well i'm willing to
break 20 laws but not 21.
i got to draw the line somewhere a man
has to have some standards after all
i have my doubts about that and anyway
it doesn't matter or it shouldn't matter
because the second amendment still
exists as much as biden and his ilk wish
it didn't
that wasn't the only disturbing answer
that we heard there was also this
on the subject of masks the cdc is going
to say that what you should do is
everyone over the age of under the age
of 12
should probably be wearing a mask in
school that's probably what's going to
happen
secondly those over the age of 12 who
are able to get vaccinated if you're
vaccinated
you shouldn't wear a mask if you aren't
vaccinated you should be wearing a mask
everyone under the age of 12.
this manages somehow to be a more
moderate position than the one taken by
the american academy of pediatrics
which like we talked about yesterday
they announced that all kids
ages three and up should be wearing
masks vaccinated or not
the entire school day and presumably
outside of school too if they should be
wearing it in school why shouldn't they
be wearing it
out of school the latter position was
echoed by cnn doctor
uh jonathan reiner who who called for
every kid going to school of any age
any vaccination status to uh wear a mask
let's listen to that
what is the safest bet for kids when
school reopens in a matter of weeks
yeah so i think uh every kid going to
school should be masked
uh vaccinated or not and i know this is
this angers
uh people who have been vaccinated but
we need to protect
everyone and we really can't tell who's
been vaccinated and who hasn't i think
every
kid going to school should have a mask
on to protect
those who just have chosen not to be
vaccinated and those who can't be
uh you know moreover i think we need to
accelerate vaccinations among
adolescents we've only vaccinated
about a third of eligible adolescents in
this country
this is a preventable illness every
state in the united states
requires vaccinations for school-age
kids
why is this vaccine any different
preventable illness
and he's right it is preventable do you
know for kids
um in almost every case what what
prevents
the illness for them their immune system
so he's saying we need we need to they
need to wear the masks to protect
well to protect who who are you
protecting all of the adults working at
a school
have the opportunity to get vaccinated
and the vast majority
certainly have been by now 80 percent of
teachers were vaccinated by the end of
march
so where are we now those that's just
the latest number i happen to see
i'm i'm quite certain we are near 100
at this point and even if they weren't
even last year when they
weren't vaccinated still the kids posed
almost no risk to them
which is why the data showed that that
schools were not
vectors for transmission as had been
predicted by the covid
panic pushers why is that because kids
by and large
are an extremely low risk to get
seriously sick from covet or to spread
it
we've always known this so who is their
mask protecting
who was it ever protecting now the
adults in school are vaccinated and the
kids again are not at any serious risk
at all
an article in new york magazine
published yesterday as well actually
made this point
reading now it says the kids are safe
they always
have been it may sound strange given a
year of panic over school closures and
reopenings a year of masking toddlers
and closing playgrounds and huddling in
pandemic pods
that according to cdc among children the
mortality risk from kova 19 is actually
lower than from the flu
the risk of severe disease or
hospitalization is about the same
this is true for the much worried over
delta variant it's also true for all of
the other variants and for the original
strain
most remarkably it has been known to be
true since the very earliest days of the
pandemic
indeed it was among the very first
things we did know about the disease
the preliminary mortality data from
china was very clear to children
covenanting represented only a
vanishingly tiny threat
of disease hospitalization or severe uh
or of death
hospitalization or severe disease now i
read that to you because
new york magazine is uh is is is not a
right wing publication to put up mildly
and this is all incontrovertibly true
you can't get around this
if kids should be masked for covet even
now
when with most adults vaccinated then
kids should be masked
all the time forever due to all the
other diseases that pose a much greater
statistical risk
though i'm i'm realizing this maybe is
not the best way to frame the argument
i realize that saying well if kids have
to wear masks for covid then they should
wear masks for everything
that's not the best way to get through
to the mask cultists at this point
because they're likely to just say yeah
okay
great idea let's put masks on them for
everything all the time
these people are such terminal cowards
and their minds are so deluded and
damaged
that they're happy to have children live
every day as though the very air they
breathe
is fatally toxic they would muzzle their
kids deprive them of a normal life a
normal childhood
like the one that they had and the
opportunity to do basic things like see
each other's
faces and smiles and they would do all
of this
are doing all of this simply to satiate
their own
outlandish paranoia
putting masks on kids at this point at
any point really but especially now
is not only anti-science not only
irrational and illogical
not only does it contradict the data and
the evidence but it's also child abuse
in my opinion
it's become a form of monsoon by proxy
making your kid
act like he's sick or think that he
might become deathly sick
and doing this all to satisfy your own
strange psychological needs
but the good news is that these mandates
require our
cooperation we can simply say
no i'm not putting this thing on my
kid's face just to make you feel better
it's not going to happen
and then let the chips fall where they
may we're going to have to get to that
point
if we're not there already because it's
clear it has and has
been clear from the beginning
that the tyrants simply will not ever
let up otherwise
now let's get to our five headlines
the daily wire team in nashville
continues to grow we currently have
multiple open positions across the
company all of which can be viewed at
dailywire.com
careers this week we're highlighting the
paid media buyer
opening the uh this member of the daily
wire marketing team will create and
execute paid media campaigns for
daily wire we're looking for someone who
is skilled with organization time
management and attention to detail
at least one year of previous
professional experience in a paid media
buyer or similar role is required
and excel proficiency is crucial this is
an in-office position in nashville
tennessee so your qualified candidates
should apply through dailywire.com
careers here's some more good news for
you this is from
gallup it says for the second
consecutive year
u.s adults positive ratings of relations
between black and white americans are at
their lowest point in more than two
decades of measurement
currently 42 percent of americans say
relations between the two groups are
very or somewhat good
while 57 say they are somewhat or very
bad
the most recent rating of black white
relations in the us is not statistically
different from last year's 44
however the reading has eroded nine
percentage points over the past two
years as the nation has grappled with
the murder of george floyd
and the subsequent nationwide protests
and calls for
racial justice a lot of air quotes
around much of what i just read there
especially protests calls for racial
justice
um as recently as 2001 70 of us adults
raided black white relations positively
that changed after several high-profile
killings of unarmed black people by
police officers around the us
uh now i think this is worth pointing to
this poll for a couple of reasons number
one
um back in 2001 70 rating it positively
and that kind of confirms especially
people in my generation
what we've always what what we remember
it's
this is not just us looking back
nostalgically through rosy colored
glasses as people tend to do
uh idealizing their past and their
childhood it's not just that because my
memory um of my own childhood and
and uh adolescent a teenager in high
school middle school
my memory is that this all of this
racial
stuff it wasn't an issue we didn't talk
about it
or think about it um
i went to schools that were
very racially diverse and it i don't
remember it being an
issue it wasn't something that we talked
about we didn't we didn't sit around the
critical race theory had not
it existed out there but it hadn't made
its way into this into the school system
at that level yet
and so we didn't we didn't sit around
every day talking about our racial
differences and the fact that we're
white in our whiteness and what that
means and everything
there was there was other forms of
left-wing indoctrination that i
recognized even at the time
but not that as far as that goes we kind
of went about our day
as kids and whatever wasn't an issue
that's certainly my memory of it and the
polls if you look back at the polls and
surveys whatever they tell us
that would appear to to back that up
um it's an issue now why is it an issue
how's this happened well gallup says
that it's because of police shootings
but that's not it because we know that
there has not been
if if there had been over the last
couple of years an epidemic
of innocent unarmed men unarmed black
men being murdered by the police
then a huge spike an epidemic of this
kind of thing
then maybe the reason they're giving
here might make some kind of sense but
that epidemic
doesn't exist it's not real
as i have and i've presented the data
many times i've written about it
this is another incontrovertible fact
the vast majority of police shootings
are entirely justified clearly justified
um and in the majority cases the the
criminal
the person who is shot is armed
themselves
killings of unarmed people black are
white
extremely rare and it happens more often
to white
people than it does to black people
extremely extremely rare and even in
many of those cases
it's it is still a justified killing
because very often the purp the perp is
in the process
of trying to kill police officers some
other way like for instance instance
trying to run them over with a car
that counts as unarmed so that's what
the facts say
um but the media has taken these things
as you have noticed
and they have created this racial
narrative
if this is their fault so this is their
handiwork the media
they can look at this gallup poll and
they can kind of say well
our work here is done or maybe not done
but perhaps our work here is just
beginning
our work has been a success so far phase
one
successful they can say
this is all very intentional this is
exactly what this is
exactly the effect that they want to
have this is the impact they were
looking for
because the epidemic of of racist white
cops
hunting down black men and killing them
that is a media invention and they know
that they're inventing it and there's a
reason why they're doing it because this
is what they want
um and why do they want it
a lot of reasons for that for one thing
and we could never forget about this
motivation when it comes to the media
anyway this is always going to be the
number one motivation for everything
it you know ratings money uh money talks
it gives them something to talk about
you know blm rating the blm riots great
for business for the media
they can take a police shooting and uh
george floyd
great for business for the media
and also it makes people easier to
manipulate politically when there's this
kind
of racial tension tribalism
um it's it's politically convenient it's
good for business
and that's the reason it's pretty simple
but this is all them they have done that
and now we're bringing into schools and
we're and we're bringing this to kids
and we are telling kids now from a very
young age
you know we are forcing them
not just to notice the racial
differences because of course anyone
notices you see someone who looks
different from you
and you notice that they look different
from you it's one thing to simply
notice it and then go about your day
but with the media and and now what the
school system is saying is no this
difference
we want you to notice it we want you to
focus on it
we want you to think a lot about it
and by the way if you're a white person
even i hate to tell you but you are
there's all kinds of guilt that you that
you have inherited
and you need to apologize
for things you had nothing to do with
yeah funny enough when you do that
you've laid the groundwork and you're
gonna end up with um
race relations
being in pretty bad shape bad shape
relatively speaking
to those of us who are just honest
decent people we would call it bad
the media though it's not bad for them
this is great for them it's what they
want
all right this is from al.com
down in alabama i don't know i i i i
i'm skeptical about so many things but
you you tell me okay
this one was being passed around on uh
on social media quite a bit yesterday
that's how i came across it so this is
what the article says
says dr brittany cobia said said monday
that all but
one of her coven 19 patients in alabama
did not receive the vaccine
the vaccinated patient she said uh just
need a little oxygen is expected to
fully recover
some of the others are dying cobia a
hospitalist at grandview medical center
in birmingham in an emotional facebook
post sunday said
i'm admitting young people young healthy
people to the hospital with very serious
covet infections
one of the last things they do before
they're intubated is begging me for the
vaccine
i hold their hand and tell them that i'm
sorry but it's too late
um cobia told al.com
back in 2020 and early 2021 21 when the
vaccine wasn't available it was just
tragedy after tragedy of strategy
you know so many people that did all the
right things and yet still came in and
were critically
uh ill and died it says in the united
states covet is now a pandemic of the
unvaccinated so on and so forth we know
about that
um kobe continued on facebook a few days
later when i call
time of death i hug their families
family members and i tell them
the best way to honor their loved one is
to go get vaccinated and encourage
everyone they know to do the same okay
now here's the part where the skepticism
comes in
they cry and they tell me they didn't
know
they thought it was a hoax they thought
it was political they thought because
they had a certain blood type or skin
color
they wouldn't get as sick they thought
it was just the flu
but they were wrong and they wish they
could go back but they can't
so they thank me and they go get the
vaccine and i go back to my office
write their death note and say a small
prayer that this loss will save more
lives
okay that's the part there
uh what she's been claimed is that
multiple people in the hospital
i don't know if she's talking about the
family members of of the dead or the
people the
the the sick people right before they
die say uh
oh i thought only a certain skin color i
thought old people only of only a
certain skin color would get sick
you tell me do you do you buy that
multiple people are saying that
and the implication here obviously is
that these are white people who are
saying oh i
didn't know white people could get this
also
who who thinks that i i haven't
i've interacted with lots of people all
across
the spectrum in terms of their view of
covid
i haven't heard that from anyone i
haven't heard a single person say that
to me
so yeah call me skeptical in fact i'm
gonna i'll i'll just straight up say i
do not believe this
but this is we we have seen this over
and over again from these medical
professionals they feel the need to
um you know
to kind of to kind of puff up the story
a little bit exaggerate a little bit
and then you you lose credibility
because otherwise
the fact that she's dealt with dying
covered patients i certainly believe
that
it's a very upsetting and horrible thing
i believe that
most of the people that are seriously
sick from kova that she's dealing with
now are unvaccinated
certainly believe that too so stick with
that
and tell us about your experiences
that's fine
but you feel the need to racialize it
make it political
and then all of the credibility is is
out the window everything else you said
no one's paying attention anymore
all right next is from the daily wire it
says a uh a well-known black
social activist targeted famed harry
potter author
uh jk rowling on wednesday patronizely
patronizingly avoiding her name and
tweeting jk rowling is just another
violent white woman brie newsome who was
lauded by then-presidential candidate
hillary clinton in 2016 for shimmying up
the flagpole and removing the
confederate flag from the south carolina
state house 2015
apparently was referring to rowling's
exchange regarding the transgender
community
as she continued ranting talking about
jk rowling she said
what she did is classic violent white
woman behavior go out of her way to use
her powerful position to target a
minority group that already experiences
daily systemic violence
and then claim that she's the real
victim when there's backlash
unlike those she targeted for no reason
who are already disproportionately the
victims of violence murder and hate
crimes
she can afford personal security uh can
even afford to live isolated in luxury
if she wants to she's
she sees no connection has no empathy a
violent personality
as the article goes on to talk about uh
while jk rowling is
is accused of being violent committing
violence against people because of
for for sharing her opinion her opinion
which is
which should not qualify as conservative
or right wing or anything
um her opinion
is in fact i'm not even sure if she goes
this far i was going to say that her
opinion is that there there are
you know biological differences between
men and women and that's what determines
what what your sex is but i'm not even
sure if maybe she's gone that far
if we could call that going far um
mainly she just doesn't think that you
know men should be in locker rooms with
women and that sort of thing
um and she is the one who has received
death threats
um you know there was someone who
tweeted at her
over the weekend and that she was
responding to
who said that she wishes someone would
put up would put a uh a pipe
pipe bomb in her mailbox and that kind
of thing
now i bring this up because jk rowling
uh left-wing author
she is one of the few people that we've
seen i think she deserves some credit
she's one of the few people that we've
seen
that has experienced this kind of
intense
sustained backlash for years now
i i can only imagine you see what's
what's tweeted at her what people say to
her and comments
publicly openly threatening to kill her
so whatever you see publicly keep in
mind that it's going to be about 10
times worse
in the private messages she gets and
she's been getting that
for months and probably years now and
has not let up and she wasn't backing
down here
either and i'll give her some credit for
that
yeah now yes she's a
multi-multi-millionaire
and so she can afford to tell these
people to
piss off basically
but being a multi-millionaire and having
a lot of money that hasn't stopped many
other people from caving anyway
uh but she has so i probably don't agree
with her on
anything else but on this at least
when i see someone simply just standing
their ground
um making a really obvious common sense
observation
or expressing an opinion that's
obviously the correct opinion
and then getting this insane reaction
and standing firm and saying
that's my opinion i'm not gonna
apologize for it
anyone who does that now i uh
i feel a need to give them
at least a little bit of credit for that
because it's so it's unfortunately so
rare
all right this is also from the daily
wire it says fashion magazine marie
claire
wants to see more parents getting
abortions on network television and in
films
using the popular left-wing obsession of
representation the 84-year-old
women's publication ran an article on
july 16th worrying that if more
women who are already mothers don't see
characters like themselves killing their
unborn children
they might not choose to do so as well
and that would be
what a tragedy that would be does that
mean that more more children are born we
can't have that
author danielle campemore who also
has written for the new york times
washington post and vanity fair promoted
her piece on twitter saying parents are
the most common abortion patients
it's time we see ourselves having
abortions on screen
in the story she argues countless
studies have highlighted the importance
of representation in the media be it
race gender relationships body size and
shape mental health or disability status
the same is true of abortion but
accurate depictions of the most common
abortion patients parents
parents is still severely lacking you
know
the thing that stands out about about
this to me
is uh yeah it's it's deranged and
twisted that
you want to see more abortions on screen
at all whether you want to see any
abortions on screen in the first place
but think about that she says the most
common
abortion patients quote unquote are
parents
uh but we don't see but anytime there's
a story involving abortions
in a in a movie or a show it's not
usually it's not a parent getting the
abortion
and that's a problem for this writer
well hang on a second no no
let me correct you it's not that
parents are the most common people to
get abortions
it's actually that by definition every
single person who has ever gotten an
abortion
is a parent that is exclusively
going to be parents every single person
by definition because if you're getting
an abortion it means that you're a
mother
and that's not semantics at all this is
not this is not splitting hair that's a
that's a
very important point
because that this is the message that
they're kind of sneaking in here with
something like this
forget about all the stupid stuff about
representation
the message is that if you
are a woman and you get pregnant and you
don't have any other kids who are born
then you're not a mother yet you're not
a parent you're not a mother or a parent
until the baby is born
and uh so if you go and and get an
abortion
then you you're you're not a parent
you can remain not a parent
but that is not the case once you
the moment that your child comes into
existence
you are a parent again by definition
you have offspring that that's what a
parent is look it up in the dictionary
and so the moment that the child is
conceived comes into existence as a
physical
entity distinct from yourself
another organism which is what a child
in the womb at any stage
the child in the womb is a separate
organism biologically scientifically
and that that organism is your offspring
you are the parent
the mother and as i have uh
tried to communicate many times and not
not as a way of
of not even as a as
a way of of heaping guilt or anything
just as a as a
um as a
simple observation
when you get the abortion you don't go
back to not being a mother you are now
the mother of a dead child
i think that's very important to realize
something has happened here
in the conception of that child that
cannot be undone
and that's the lie that they get from
the abortion industry
you know they what they're told is that
is that pregnancy
is this kind of no man's land um it
gives you nine months to just decide
you you don't have a kid yet and if you
decide that you want the kid then then
magically now you are the mother
but it's a it's a it's kind of a
nine-month return policy sort of
situation
that's not the way it goes in conception
something has happened that cannot
cannot be undone a life has come into
existence you can kill that life
but you're still a mother now you're the
mother of a dead child
all right let's move move now to read in
the youtube comments this is from
uh joe shack he says we will never
relate to matt's lived experience
of suffering with uh cvd that's color
vision deficiency and i
there were a lot of comments about color
vision deficiency a lot of people
relating to my lived experience who are
in this community maybe didn't realize
that they
also are are in a victim group like like
i am and
so that's the good news um
fortitude says matt you should try the
enchroma glasses for color blindness
they actually help you see colors way
better i know this because i also am
color deficient
and the glasses have helped more than i
thought they would
well i have to say fortitude i think
it's ironic you call yourself fortitude
but you are a traitor to the cvd
community
this is our this is this is this is who
we are this is our identity it's people
who can't see color i don't know
i honestly don't know what color this
shirt is and that's not a joke
i know it's either red or brown possibly
green
but that is my that's my experience
that's who i am
i could wear glasses to reject that
identity
um bryce says matt has a medical
condition that doesn't allow him to
pronounce someone's name the same way
twice
aoc and kamela are different every
single time even bezos became bezos
i don't know what you're talking about i
always get these comments from people
remarking on the way i pronounce names i
i don't know what you mean
um and scott says so as a visually
disabled colorblind individual do you
walk around
tapping a crayon on the ground ahead of
you
that that's deeply offensive to me those
kinds of stereotypes
it's not a joke garf says between his
wife's insulting tweets and his
producers insulting polls i've come to
think of matt as the most oppressed man
on the internet
wait the producers insult me with their
what are you talking about
am i being insulted by my own producers
in the comments section
we just asked about your clothes just
ask about my clothes
this is see this this this is the
persecution i suffer on a daily basis
everywhere i turn you know the only
place i can turn
to feel welcome and welcomed and like i
belong is uh
is to the sweet baby gang speaking of
which
you know we played this sweet baby gang
anthem a couple days ago i thought it
was a
beautiful work of art many other people
now are
making their own sweet baby gang songs
and i kind of love them all they're
they're all like my children i can't
choose which one i love the most
but here's another uh submission this is
kayla kelly you can find her on youtube
and
here is her idea vision
for a sweet baby gang anthem let's all
listen together
[Music]
where to begin
lost in the sea of leftists
trying to use my common sense
[Music]
it then becomes clear
there is a gang we belong to
led by a man with a gloriously
[Music]
thought there was no hope
it felt like the whole world had gone
woke
but now i know there's a place
and let this tears they taste so good
[Music]
remarkable remarkable
uh i i just listening to that i imagine
myself
you know standing at the at the pearly
gates
surrounded by whiteness and light and
and
listening to the the the angelic
choruses
singing that song
um beautiful song obviously goes without
saying
and uh i can't believe no one else
thought of of the sweet caroline sweet
baby gang connection until now so
brilliant those kayla kelly again
the artist there with that with that
great song uh and i love that i
am i am still waiting not to be
ungrateful but i
i am also waiting for someone to do the
banjo rendition
because at the end we gotta settle on
one anthem strong competitor there
last one we played with strong
competitor um i wanna i wanna hear what
the banjo like blue
grass sweet baby gang anthem sounds like
so we'll
we'll keep searching the search
continues there are a lot of news
podcasts
out there i'm sure you've noticed that
if you go if you go look up that
category
tons and tons of them but the problem is
that many are packed with leftist
propaganda
and that's why from the daily wire
newsroom we present morning wire the
morning podcast that values your time
and the truth we're thrilled to see that
our listeners share our appreciation of
the facts because the podcast just
launched this week
and it's already the number two podcast
on apple and number 11 on spotify
while we're proud of this we need to
help we need you to help us
get the news you need to where it
belongs at number one so subscribe now
to morning wire and apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review
if you like what you hear you also like
you're gonna like this as well um
the authoritarian moment that book ben
shapiro's new book that comes out next
tuesday july 27th
but um if you want to get a signed copy
then go to dailywire.com ben right now
to order your signed copy before
tuesday's live signups we're going to do
on tuesday when they're when the book
comes out
he's going to be signing all these books
live when you do you'll be asked to type
in a question at checkout
and then you can catch tuesday's live
signing to see if he answers your
question
and you can watch him sign your book
live what are you waiting for
get your copy at dailywire.com ben right
now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today i must address a certain pr
crisis that i've been embroiled in all
week and have tried my best to ignore
but it's obvious that i'm not going to
be able to remain silent about this
many of you especially those who watch
this show on youtube know that i often
will post music reviews to my channel
we've
reviewed all kinds of different songs by
different artists from different genres
some of the songs are artistic
masterpieces like
we paid by a little baby kuda by
takashi69 great song some were a bit
subpar
like driver's license by uh ariana
grande or whoever it was
and then there was the other song by
that chick from tiktok the point is
we have reviewed the whole gamut but
until this past weekend we had not
reviewed any k-pop music
and that was an oversight that we knew
we had to remedy k-pop for those who
aren't familiar is short for kill me now
pop
because it causes those who are
subjected to it to experience suicidal
urges
and i know what you're thinking oh
that's just regular pop music that's all
pop music and you're right
it's very similar to pop music most pop
music except this is asian and origin
the biggest group in that genre is
called bts and they're the ones i
reviewed on my channel
as i explained in that review the first
few times i heard the name bts i
confused it with btk
the buying torture kill serial killer
and i was rather disturbed frankly to
see that so many adolescent girls were
such big fans of his work
and then i found out that bts and btk
are two different things and and i was
relieved
but then i listened to the song and i
realized that in fact i might actually
prefer btk
over bts in hindsight the point is that
i
i didn't especially like the song it's
no
we paid that's for certain and so i gave
bts two thumbs up for for not being
serial killers as i previously suspected
but i did ultimately give them two
thumbs down for the song itself
which was terrible as it turns out
bts fans do not like it when you don't
like their music
even though my review was honest and
respectful
well honest anyway still the bts fans
have
flooded the comments my messages my
inbox with it with a deluge of extremely
aggressive criticism as it stands right
now
my video has about 10 000 thumbs down
and 10 000 comments
almost all of them negative and the
comments generally fall somewhere on the
scale between
i disagree with your opinion about bts
and and uh
i'm going to find you and kill you for
not liking my favorite boy band
generally leaning more towards the
latter end of that spectrum
uh and also i have been informed
especially through many messages on
twitter that um
i am ugly uh stupid white
male one message stipulated that i am
both ugly
and hideous two different things i guess
so i got all my bases covered another
adds that uh i'm an
ugly jealous and my face looks like
many comments took exception to the fact
that i allegedly accused all bts fans of
being deaf
and i've been informed that this is
bigotry and uh and miserable and i'm and
uh you know i'm a miserable
hateful sack of garbage especially for
making a comment like that
during what is apparently disability
awareness month
many other comments insisted that i need
to do my research before
talking about bts again and on and on
and on in summary people really didn't
like the video
really really really didn't like it
now this is the daily cancellation so
you're probably expecting that i'm gonna
now
cancel all of these salty pop fans for
getting so mad about my music review
but i would not dream of adding to the
trauma that i've already caused them
in fact today for the first time
i'm going to cancel myself and also for
the first time i am going to say
sincerely and i really mean this
i i'm sorry i apologize bts fans i am
sorry
truly though i'm afraid i've been
misunderstood
yeah i accused you of being deaf i
didn't mean it as an
insult i just assumed that you must be
deaf
if you can listen to that music without
dry heaving
that's it you know it's it's like when
you see a woman with a beer gut and you
say congratulations on the pregnancy and
she says i'm not pregnant
you you were going on context clues and
you arrived at the wrong conclusion
i was incorrect in my assumptions and
i'm sorry i'm also sorry for being ugly
hideous white and male if i could do it
over again i would have identified as a
beautiful woman before
recording that video that's what i
should have done that was my own
oversight
i take ownership of that and i apologize
for not doing my research
um i spent six months
reading through volumes of information
and literature before reviewing takashi
69
for example i traveled across the globe
i consulted experts i sought guidance
and insight
i climbed to the top of a mountain i
meditated alongside a tibetan monk
i prayed and fasted all to prepare me
for that youtube video
but for the bts video i admit i did none
of that
no research no consultation no prayer in
fact
i'll leave in a minute we decided to do
that video at the last minute
because we couldn't think of any other
content and
i put literally no preparation into it
whatsoever
a disaster followed this is my fault
and mine alone but also mainly the
producers they should have stopped me
so blame them and i will live with the
regret for the rest of my days
i haven't slept all week i i'm i'm
tormented by the terrified screams of
bts fans who discovered for the first
time that not everyone shares their
taste in music
their tears haunt me their anger
their disappointment it stabs like a
knife into my soul
much like the music stabbed like a knife
into my eardrums
what else can i do now but plead for
your forgiveness
i never meant to cause you pain i want
only for you to feel joy
and happiness in this world and in the
words of bts
from their song butter sidestep
right left to my beat hi like the moon
rock with me baby
know that i got that heat
i don't know what that means but i'm
sure it applies here somehow
and all i can say now is that today once
and for all
i am canceled
and we'll leave it there on that somber
note
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of the
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode senator rand paul and
dr anthony fauci
spar over gain of function research
teachers groups gather to discuss
race and social justice and negotiations
over the infrastructure bill
appear to be wrapping up join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know
with our show morning wire